will take five random suggestions can be
anything you want within those rules and
then we'll drop a beat and have some fun
so if you are sat kind of I guess in
this kind of rectangle here suggestion
number one what would you like to rap
about
Ireland let's be more specific let's
really kind of duck in what about
Ireland
England invading Ireland lovely thank
you very much
um no why not
why not
you know you could have you know could
have said anything and you chose that
and I suppose I suppose that's my fault
um
and if not my fault then at least my
great great grandfather's
um
people over here what would you like a
rap about
The Wizard of Oz thank you very much
um is there a particular aspect of The
Wizard of Oz that you're particularly
enamored
Toto the little little dog great cool
I I heard that and I was like they did
not do the soundtrack for The Wizard of
Oz it's not Africa is not in The Wizard
of Oz
all right um it's a banger in it okay
Toto the dog and The Wizard of Oz middle
middle of the room watch you guys like a
rap about
Costco what a strange tone of voice to
say that in
Costco
deals at Costco
[Music]
are you a human what is this are you
like a new
your
Google's new Ai and they put it in a
Flash thing great Costco Costco
Ireland and uh England invading Island
Costco is a store they have over here
where they buy things in bulk
um it's just they don't have it in
Ireland because because we ruined their
country didn't we so yeah I'm really
trying to Keep Her On Side by because in
the wrap I'm probably gonna say
something horrendously offensive
um great and Wizard of Oz and Toto two
more suggestions suggestion from this
corner
wow wow some real fans in here
um yeah what do you want to rapper
do I want to talk about what sorry
anal glands
you're a veterinarian and you want me to
rap about a dog's anal glands
for you I would rap about anything
[Laughter]
um
it's amazing he said Costco and it
sounded like an automaton and you were
like a dog's anal glands
um I'm in love with you
you and my wife would get on really
there's lots of
dog anal glands in her day as well okay
cool well this is what we're gonna do
it's a it's a it's a wrap made up on the
spot based and all those suggestions
Island and the British invading it Toto
the dog in The Wizard of Oz a dog's anal
glands
Kanye and the Jews it's probably the
medley's favorite aspect of it and um
and Costco you don't need to remind me
what the [__] was that
I mean it is very late and this tea is
uncaffeinated
okay let's uh let's drop this beat let's
see if that's all playing oh it is yeah
oh yeah it's quite nice it's got a weird
little sample to start but let's uh
let's drop this beat unless uh let's do
it cool
[Music]
the base hits then it's off we go my man
likes to gather [__] nearby at Costco
walking in mustache on the face looking
hard like a lumberjack flashing out his
Costco card who'd the thunker that I
feel so complete on the way how they ask
you to check your receipt No Stealing no
theft in the trolley you got none in
your country and for that I'm sorry I'm
a British guy yes I feel swole anyway
back he's buying all that roll all the
paper products no whiffs no butts get
the free samples till he fills his guts
he maybe puts on some type of Disguise
walks in it's kind of sneaky kind of
snide when you get a free little bliny
you take it out there feeling unseemly
llama ancestors treated all of your
people ever sold Jolly but they weren't
equal the British people were walking
over like um yes we'll take over here we
go half of the course let's break it up
yes this spits the North doesn't really
work we get a lot of [__] I'm slightly
confused Protestants and Catholics why
did they fight oh so much hope the
people over there they're loving the
pope they've got the Falls Road dividing
the areas Irish accents there's really
nothing scarier they sound fun you're
like I'll admit this I'm chilling out
having all the pints of Guinness
leprechauns and then oh Lucky Charms but
you hear their voice and their hairs on
your arms stand up it's like ah hello
today I can't do the accent but the IRA
they wanna Bond my people yes they do
and that's fine everybody would agree
with you moving on from that area we had
it before the English and the Irish they
be stoking the war and that's a modern
day contemporary thing you do if your
names Kanye then you hate the Jews you
just sat there going on Fox News saying
Tucker Carson I'm just like you an
anti-semitic man with the platform it's
so sad to see he really scorned all the
people indeed as they cut him off
swiftly technically they took too long
for me I was like no I'm gonna burn my
Yeezys I don't own any please don't see
me and put me on Twitter and say what I
think I genuinely hope they don't put
him in the clink don't cancel him he
made some good music in the past
admittedly the current ones are like ass
and what type of ass it fits the job the
metaphor got the ass of a certain dog
we're gonna combine this we're doing the
show understand anal glands on the back
of Toto he's there on the yellow brick
road sees the little witch Wicked off
the West going Toe to Toe crushed by the
house he's feeling kind of funky it's
stung in my butt wait there's the flying
monkeys Toto go go give the bite he's
like don't worry Dorothy I'll fight I've
got a big plan [__] The Lion and the Tin
Man but still I've got a problem with my
little butt glands maybe the best he
could get Dorothy got her Kansas pet go
to the vet the vet says we can just
Express that's the technical term yeah
the Vets impressed he knows this I'm
aware of them that's my girl sexy
veterinarian got the dog's anal glands
yeah that's what we do what color are
they red like Dorothy's shoes
[Applause]